on apprend bien soin des yeux humains
ont pu voir à travers le hublot de la
capsule la terre rouler dans l'infini
l'événement est une première dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
le 12 avril 1961 il a tout juste 60 ans
un être humain voyager dans l'espace
cet homme c'est le soviétique youri
gagarine
je me sens en pleine forme le vol se
poursuit mais les vibrations augmente le
soviétique vient de décoller du
cosmodrome de baïkonour au kazakhstan
pendant une heure 48 à bord du vaisseau
vostok 1 où tourne autour de la terre à
plus de 300 km d'altitude et j'observe
la terre je distingue le relief les
forêts les nuages
au bout de quelques minutes de voyage
gagarine survol l'amérique et les états
unis
le moment choisi par l'urss au annoncé
par radio la nouvelle au monde entier
nous ce que vous parle et
le premier homme dans l'espace est un
citoyen soviétique sa mission effectuée
le soviétique s'extrait de sa capsule en
plein vol il atterri en parachute à 800
km de moscou sur les bords de la volga
l'exploit est saluée partout dans le
monde
gagarine fait la une des journaux
internationaux à des milliers de
kilomètres de là les français n'en
reviennent pas pour que c'est formidable
pour la russie c'est quand même un grand
exploit
que les hommes sont arrivés à une chose
pareille je trouve qu'il a beaucoup de
chance je voudrais bien être à sa place
quelques jours après son vol iouri
gagarine est de retour à moscou
il est accueilli par une foule en délire
et devient un héros national
deux cosmonautes et décoré par le leader
soviétique léonid brejnev une ovation
ininterrompue a conduit l'homme dans
l'espace jusqu'à la place rouge et à la
tribune du mausolée de lénine la foule
qu'on a évalué à plus d'un million de
personnes a pu acclamer à loisir l'homme
qui peut le premier se vanter d'avoir vu
de ses yeux la terre ronde comme une
boule
après moscou le soviétique entame une
tournée dans le monde entier
prague londres varsovie il devient un
symbole de propagande pour l'urss
ironie du sort youri gagarine meurt dans
un accident d'avion
c'était le 27 mars 1968 il avait
seulement 34 ans
[Musique]